but this guy is so important to the red
sox as they try to get some of their
other guys healthy
and he's just go get him he throws a lot
of strikes early he's uh
a guy that can light up the radar gun
here's the one-two and he swings and
grounds a breaking ball to second base
arroyo has it fires to dalbeck one two
three first inning
for nate of aldi
tampa bay nothing red sox coming up
here's the pitcher very different look
left-hander ryan yarborough and they
call it contact suppression his
specialty yeah he's got a great
deception to his delivery and he creates
an illusion to the hitter that the
ball's going to get there and it doesn't
so he relies a lot on spin
garbo likes to take advantage of over
aggressive hitters
feasts on long swings
and evers goes fishing you don't have to
just fire the baseball and
let your stuff take care of hitters see
that arm angle and that release point
good luck to yarbrough against jd
martinez first pitch swing and going the
other way we'll see if it's playable for
a rosarina in right field
and he's got it in his glove
catch is made right next to the fans
great to have fans back for 2021 randy
arose arena unfazed
what a play
last catch or maybe catch from randy
rosarina is under review at the moment
i mean we really had no clue what was
going on
i think it went through
different set of hands and then it ended
up in his glove is it interference at
the end of the day he ended up with the
baseball in the mid so
i mean that looks clean to me right
there i think that's an out no problem
and we will continue
the first inning
that one on the ground gobbled up at
third
and wendell retires martinez so that
will officially conclude the first
inning top of the third inning with
manny marco leading off seven eight and
nine coming up for tampa bay chopper
over ivaldi and here comes bogarts
bare-handed
for the out
what a play right there
senate board showing what he's capable
of doing you know he did not waste any
time in charging this baseball as soon
as he saw it he went after it and he
knows who's running he has to hurry
he's bare-handed very cleanly
very athletic move
we shouldn't ever take this for granted
i mean that is a lot harder than it
looks
race won the first two games of the
season
getting a timely hit or two
and some really really good pitching as
the 1-0 pitch is slashed down the left
field line and that's fair it's going to
roll all the way to the corner toward
the big monster
and the green monster i should say in
order to go dig it out of the corner jd
martinez around first and on his way to
second base is mahea and he's in with a
one-out double in the rays have their
first hit of the afternoon back to the
top of the lineup in yoshi sugo go
grounded out
in the top of the first
off the end of the bat broken bat and
it's going to fall in front of hernandez
here comes mejia and he's in there
drives in the first run of the day for
tampa bay it's one nothing
when you see the splitter right there it
stays in the strike zone doesn't tumble
and he hits it off the end of the bat
and
that's one you're gonna go back and go i
know if i execute it's still an out but
i like my chances better with velocity
over the middle of the zone
he is a gentle giant too
true gentleman
soft-spoken the 1-1 pitch is a little
blooper into shallow right field racing
in on it renfro he dives and he makes
the play
what a grab by hunter renfro that was
almost trouble too
not loud contact but effective for the
raise the red sox the last couple of
days playing great defense you hope
renfrow's okay
diaz swings through
that was a great combination right there
spolts if you watch the pitch prior to
that was an up and in fastball and diaz
was laid on it and then he throws the
slider off of exactly the same line and
diaz is ahead of it
see there's the pitch right there that's
not even close
flowecky cleans it up
a pair of punch-outs for native aldi
xander bogarts
with devers on second
bogarts golfs it to center and that's
going to fall in front of margot
rounding third is devers and he's gonna
score
xander bogarts evens this game up at one
with the rbi knock
he's just too good against left-handed
pitchers right now he's just too good in
general he's not a
it's one of those simple approach
doesn't miss his pitch
but he has really had success against
left-handed pitching 10 home runs in his
first four seasons in the big leagues
and then a career-high 23 all of a
sudden in 2019
2-1 offering is blasted
christian vasquez lives up to his new
name and goes long
on cue scotty on cube we'll see what
that pitch was but it seemed like it was
something up and in it might have been
that cutter and christian vasquez was
ready for it he got ready early enough
to be able to get his swinging
and a healthy ride in the dugout it's
the new celebration you hit a homer
you ride the roller coaster hone in on
like a grip and a feeling of it and
in a matter of like a bullpen or two i
was like okay i have like a pretty
average slider that i can go and and
like compete with and then that season
went on or a spring one on
oh yeah
as spring went on
uh
you apologize that's nice of it
hitless this afternoon
but off to a 10 for 23 start
two homers five doubles
and he gives that ball a ride
deep left will it stay fair
and it's high off the wall
and it'll score a couple runs for boston
plowecki comes in so does hernandez
and jd martinez has himself a run
scoring double it's 4-1
he
boston
slightly early on this
pitch right here but he was able to keep
that barrel
in the zone for long enough
and his teammate is the first player in
red sox history with an extra base hit
in his first six games of the season
starting to show a little bit of their
old self when they were a
crooked number machine meaning they
could put up a crooked number in any one
of those nine innings
and now drops one into shallow left and
that'll score another one for boston
jd come on down it's 6-1
like hunter renfro oh for two today
broke his back
serves one up here for adamus
and the throw skips away
and bogart comes home it's 7-1
and here comes another it's vasquez
racing around they go
key mishap
from tampa bay on defense
and it opens this one up
you're not going to see this too often
it's about as routine as it gets here's
the pitch
swinging a little looper behind first
base this one may drop it does another
run scores
and into second goes arroyo as tatuko
has a hard time picking it up by the
tarp and it's 9-1 red sox
and the hits just keep on coming
well it's getting fun now i mean that
wasn't exactly smoked but arroyo will
take that double
all day long you mentioned it yeah bro
is out there big difference in his last
outing
as if there was numbers to to back it up
3-2 swing and a miss he struck him out
with a 92 mile an hour cutter the camp
looking at everybody decision makers in
the eye oh two check swing he went
around and rose arena is struck out on a
slider from evaldi one two swing and a
miss he struck him out 99 miles an hour
nate's biggest best fastball
swing the bat swing the bat
that's what mike brasso does to left
open space and it's going to drop
in comes a rose arena
and the rays double their run total
2-2 to odom
did he go
yes he did
game over
red sox take the game red sox sweep the
series 9-2